hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my Doctor Strange Easter egg video
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the movie yet some of them were
really obvious some of them even teased
Marvel characters that we haven't seen
yet so here we go so most of these are
chronological order but start with some
of the big ones first so most of you
probably saw that the eye of agamotto
really was the time gem even though they
didn't actually call it out is the time
gem you just said you have to look at
him messing with the Apple the way he
traps Dormammu in that loop and then
later when Wong says you shouldn't be
walking around the streets of New York
with an infinity stone wrapped around
your neck so then it all kind of clicks
in your head oh my god Time gem but as
he takes it off he hasn't mastered it
yet he'll also probably use it to learn
to see through time use it for more of
the clairvoyant stuff that it can do in
the comics so now we're down to the soul
gem which will probably show up
somewhere during Thor Ragnarok but then
right at the beginning of the movie when
he's performing that operation they're
arguing about Chuck Mangione
is it 1977 versus 1978 the original
Doctor Strange TV show debuted in 1978
Stan Lee one of his big missions once he
became publisher of Marvel was to sell
the movie and TV rights and get stuff
going he got that Doctor Strange thing
going that in the Hulk TV show during
the 70s where some of Marvel's first big
pushes into Hollywood but the problem is
is that the Doctor Strange TV show
debuted alongside roots so naturally
roots one of the most popular TV shows
in the history of America just
completely destroyed Doctor Strange
so barely anybody saw it and that was
the end of the Doctor Strange TV show
when he's in the Lambo before he gets
into his accident he's thumbing through
patients that he's thinking about taking
on he talks about an army colonel an
experimental armor that was hurt
that's probably roadie from Civil War
even though the director said that it
wasn't but they also talked about
another person who was struck by
lightning that might be Captain Marvel
they did say there was a Captain Marvel
Easter Egg and when asked about this the
director was also very tight-lipped he
was basically just hinted that yeah
that's probably going to be Captain
Marvel but just remember that they've
already confirmed they're changing
captain Marvel's origin story for the
movies it's not going to be the same way
it worked in the comics it'll probably
something to do with her absorbing
cosmic energy but that might be with
that lightning bolt is going way back to
winter soldiers Stephen strange got a
big shout out he was on hydras list
Kevin Feige explained that that's only
because of his extreme aptitude because
as of that time he was still just a
regular doctor so not because they knew
that he would become sorcerer supreme
just because he was smart enough that he
could become a threat to Hydra one day
this one's kind of funny the Benjamin
Bratt basketball scene so when he goes
to see Pangborn and ask him how he was
healed when he was incurable
Benjamin brats playing basketball in his
scene that's very similar to the one
where he was playing basketball in the
really terrible catwoman Halle Berry
movie so if you don't remember that
there's this really weird basketball
scene so Pangborn Benjamin Bratt playing
basketball and that's just a nice wink
at that most of these Easter eggs visual
references characters connect dr.
strange to the other Marvel films the
greater Marvel Universe but you can also
see the Avengers tower in Midtown from
the New York City skyline so you're
literally seeing stuff from other Marvel
movies but some more comic book deep
cuts early in the film when he gets into
his accident the doctor that he
chastised Nick is actually Nicodemus
West from the earth storyline the person
who actually becomes a pretty big
villain later in the movie there's
another scene that's directly ripped
right out of the o'the storyline when he
astrally projects and helps Christine
operate on himself just like giving her
directions on his body when he's first
training with Baron Mordo there are
three magical artifacts that get a shout
out there's the staff of the Living
Tribunal so everybody freaks out that
was probably one of the biggest ones
just confirming that the Living Tribunal
exists in the Marvel Universe even if we
don't see it for a long long time
there's the wand of watoomb which shows
up later in the movie Wong actually uses
it is really just like a super powerful
wand from the comics works like most
Wizard wants to and then the vaulting
boots of Valtor which we actually do not
see but that was just the Harry Potter
setup for the cloak of levitation the
wand chooses the wizard
just like the cloak chooses him later
one of the books the doctor Strange's
learning magic from is the book of the
vishanti there are three different
vishanti Oster ha goth and a komodo
they're basically like the three most
powerful magical beings in the Marvel
Universe but the way the movie uses a
komodo is that they say that he was the
first of their order like the first
sorcerer supreme like an actual person
one of the other books that he learns
from is written by cogliostro includes
passages from a 31st century sorcerer
sis neg who basically leaves notes from
the future and then the dark hold which
is also being used on agents of shield
right now so there's your agents of
shield connection they kind of subtly
referenced the dark hole during the
movie of course you know one of the most
powerful dark magic books in the world
would be referenced during Doctor
Strange mostly you probably spotted the
Stan Lee cameo when they crash into the
bus he's actually reading Otto's
Huxley's doors of perception which is
like a 1954 essay about experiences
tripping on mescaline which a lot of
people feel like was inspiration like
this 1954 book about taking drugs
creating the Doctor Strange character in
1963 so you can all fantasize about Stan
Lee and Steve Ditko taking mescaline
back in the 60s and using it to come up
with the Doctor Strange character when
Doctor Strange is first introduced to
the sorcerer supreme you meet a
one-armed master Hamir he's actually
Wong's father in the comics but the
movie doesn't use him that way the mine
trip across the multiverse that the
ancient one sends him on just to kind of
open his mind is inspired by 2001 Space
Odyssey like you even see the bleeding
colors the soundtrack even sounds a
little bit like the music from 2001
Space Odyssey but a lot of the visuals
along with the visuals in the Dark
Dimension are taken directly from Steve
Ditko's illustrations super trippy the
malice and hunger universe that she was
talking about is obviously the Dark
Dimension but they also kind of use that
as the cancerverse of the Marvel
Universe
so you can think of the Dark Dimension
as doubling as the cancerverse of the
comics which is basically just like a
darkest timeline universe with a bunch
of evil versions of all the good care
in the regular Marvel Universe more
comic book Easter eggs
Daniel drum the previous guardian of the
New York sanctum who's killed midway in
the movie is actually the brother of dr.
voodoo in the comics who eventually
himself became sorcerer supreme
after dr. strange so maybe we'll see dr.
voodoo in the movies eventually I'll do
a sequel video but beyond Baron Mordo
and Dormammu they haven't said much
about what they're going to be doing in
the sequel but speaking of which
Dormammu so he goes to the Dark
Dimension Dormammu I've come to bargain
very funny sequence but the thing is is
that Benedict Cumberbatch also voices
Dormammu the same way he voiced Sauron
during the Hobbit movies so if he didn't
watch The Hobbit movies he does mocap
for the dragon Smaug but he also does a
voice for the necromancer who is just a
form of the Dark Lord Sauron before he
pulls himself together and becomes that
great eye so Benedict Cumberbatch has a
long history of doing big formless void
evil monsters so that's kind of the way
they use Dormammu in this too they said
the reason for doing that is they wanted
Dormammu to feel like a really dark
expression of Doctor Strange like Doctor
Strange wields this almost infinite
power so they wanted Dormammu to feel
like a dark version of that and they
also said that the reason that Dormammu
looks that way is for the benefit of dr.
strange like Dormammu doesn't need to
take form but he did that mostly for the
benefit of strange just to try and freak
him out but I imagine the next time he
shows up in the movies he'll look a
little closer to the way he does in the
comics he's so powerful that in his home
dimension the one that he completely
controls he can take any form that he
wants the end of the movie obviously
kuselias and the last of his followers
get sucked into the Dark Dimension they
slowly get transformed into these
formless creatures with an eye in the
center of their face those are the
mindless ones which are very dangerous
but it's just a way of showing you what
living in dormammu's world is like he
basically turns you into a mindless one
so it's almost like a living hell so
just to end things of course the big two
post-credit scenes everybody freaked out
when we saw Thor
just implying he's going to help Thorin
Loki find Odin he's somewhere on earth
that might happen at the beginning of
Thor Ragnarok so by all accounts we'll
get a little bit of dr. strange during
Thor Ragnarok but there's also a couple
other things happening in this so it
looks like there's a time jump because
he's wearing the gloves the Doctor
Strange wears in the comics he didn't
have gloves earlier in the movie but he
also keeps a list of magical threats to
the earth Loki is on that list so he's
basically saying that he wants to get
Loki the hell off of the earth so he
doesn't cause any trouble so they're
going to find Odin as fast as possible
but the second one the Baron Mordo
post-credits scene so most people were
just kind of waiting for Baron Mordo to
do something evil during the movie he's
a big Doctor Strange villain in the
comics taking the magic from Pangborn
leaving him crippled again so when he
says there are entirely too many
sorcerers he's obviously going to
continue going around killing people who
have magic so that there are only a
couple of sorcerers left on the earth so
the follow-up on that in the sequel and
even though they haven't officially
announced the sequel Doctor Strange
crushed its opening weekend so there
will be a Doctor Strange to sometime
either later in Phase three or really
early in phase four but depending on
whatever their schedule is and Benedict
Cumberbatch's schedule so just expect
the Marvel scheduled the movie scheduled
to get shuffled just a little bit to
make room for that but let me know if
there are any other Easter eggs that you
have spotted that I didn't mention in
the video there was a whole bunch of
stuff in there Easter eggs for the TV
show back in the 70s for the comics like
the classic Steve Ditko comics for the
more modern comics like the oath in for
the other Marvel movies themselves so we
all know that Doctor Strange is going to
be a part of the Avengers they're going
to tease some Illuminati stuff that
might play out later in phase four
but I'll totally do a video for what I
think they should do during that sequel
but you know the follow up more
multiverse stuff more Doctor Strange
stuff from the comics but the movie was
a lot of fun it'll be really cool to see
them try and get even weirder with the
sequel just in the way that guardians of
the galaxy looked very different from
other Marvel movies in the way they
really double down on that for the
second movie I'm so excited about
guardians of the galaxy - I really love
the idea of Marvel doing really weird
movies so a lot of you been asking about
other Marvel's
of spider-man movie there's a rumor that
there's going to be a teaser trailer
December 2nd but that's a Friday and I
haven't been able to find a lot of
information about that so if I can find
some more concrete stuff I'll do a video
about that but more Doctor Strange more
Avengers later this week so be sure to
subscribe to get that agents of shield
is on break so is the flash so I'll be
doing some bonus videos tomorrow on
Tuesday while you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for an update on
spider-man homecoming what's going on
with the trailer when we're gonna see
footage and you can click here to learn
more about what's going on with Thor
Ragnarok thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
there are two types of beings in the
universe